[Music]
joining the final Crusade of everyone's
favorite Fedora wearing hero this week
brings another season of a badass
Monster Hunter a new animated film from
Dreamworks the return of a martial arts
heavy period show and the final mission
for Jack Ryan well at least with this
version of him anyway we've got all that
in our very own Temple of Doom or should
I say Temple of Boom because it's this
week's what to watch Hitler made
mistakes and with this I will correct
them all you stole it then you stole it
and then I stole it it's called
capitalism
whipping its way into theaters is the
action adventure flick Indiana Jones and
the dial of Destiny this marks the fifth
and final film in the franchise at least
with Harrison Ford in the leading role
which is a great reason to check this
one out we're talking movies like
Raiders of the Lost Ark Temple of Doom
the Last Crusade oh and that other
Scully one over there it's quite a list
another reason to give the leather
jacket and Fedora one final look is the
Epic cast because along with Ford will
be John Reese Davies and Karen Allen
reprising the roles as Salah and Marion
Ravenwood from earlier films and joining
them are franchise newcomers like Phoebe
Waller Bridge Antonio Banderas and mads
Mickelson as the bad guy mad Z on top of
that it's worth noting that this fresh
film is the first and only one in the
series not directed by Steven Spielberg
and which doesn't have a story by George
Lucas they are both credited as
executive producers and instead James
Mangold directed and co-wrote and that's
a good thing considering he's known for
hit films like Walk the Line Logan Ford
vs Ferrari the man's got skills if all
is coming there is no hiding her from it
sure about this
how are you premiering on Netflix this
week is the third season of the fantasy
series The Witcher after two memorable
Seasons as geralt of Rivia Henry
cavill's run will come to an end with
this two-part third season making that
the biggest reason to check it out and
FYI Liam Hemsworth will take over the
role moving forward Chris Hemsworth's
little bro critics were a little slow to
come on board during the ultimately
fresh fur season but The Witcher settled
in nicely with a 95 certified fresh
second season at a consensus that says
that the show remains a whole lot of fun
yes hunting monsters it's fun and if
you're still on the fence about entering
this fantasy world you should know that
the show is based on a popular book
series and video game and it's a vast
world that has been explored further
with an animated series and live action
mini-series spin-offs already released
on Netflix as well the women in our
family have the mighty power to turn
into giant Kraken but what now will be
you're a princess
crown
another theater option for you is the
computer animated film Ruby Gilman
teenage Kraken this coming-of-age comedy
comes from Dreamworks and if you're
looking for a good reason to see it
here's seven instead Lana Condor Tony
Collette Addie Murphy Sam Richardson
Liza koshy Will Forte and Jane Fonda aka
the film's Stellar ensemble cast and yes
Annie Murphy from shit's creek and yes
you really need to watch that show
speaking of the cast another reason to
consider Ruby Gilman teenage Kraken is
that both Lana Condor and Liza koshy
actually began working as YouTube
influencers and are now working
alongside Hollywood's Elite on the same
project its entertainment Evolution at
its finest but if you're looking for a
more familiar connection to this project
perhaps I should tell you that one of
the movie's co-writers Pam Brady
previously worked alongside Trey Parker
and Matt Stone on their hit show South
Park and their movie Team America World
Police and quote that movie yeah we have
enough enemies outside of Chinatown
I no longer want to be at War
never lasts also launching its third
season this week is the popular series
Warrior this martial arts drama is
coming off a hundred percent fresh first
season and a certified fresh second AKA
two solid reasons to give it a chance
especially when you see it's kicking
audience score is in the mid 90s if you
need more reasons or just more info
about the show it follows a martial arts
Prodigy in the late 1800s who moves from
China to San Francisco to work as a
hatchet man in Chinatown that's right
it's a period piece on top of that
Warrior is based on an original concept
and treatment by the one and only Bruce
Lee with his daughter Shannon Lee
serving as an executive producer
alongside film director Justin Lin and
something tells me Bruce definitely knew
what he was doing what are you gonna
tell him this corruption goes way higher
than the CIA hey buddy say welcome I
figured we could use the help wish me
luck
good luck and finally season four of
Jack Ryan is coming your way this week
on prime it was confirmed May of last
year that this will Mark the final
season in the series um which is a great
reason to watch whether you're finishing
it out or just jumping in with three
fresh Seasons already filed away for
this mystery thriller critics have
praised Jack Ryan for its exceptional
action sequences and of course John
krasinski's Earthly Charisma and
speaking of our boy JK he is the fifth
actor to play Jr after Alec Baldwin
Harrison Ford Ben Affleck and Chris Pine
but is Krasinski the best to do it well
I think we need to watch season four so
we can truly find out
okay that's it five picks coming at you
like a giant rolling Boulder just not
nearly as deadly be sure to let us and
your fellow viewers know in the comments
what you did check out whether it was on
this list or not remember check out
rotten tomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh
[Music]